MALE SPEAKER: Good morning and
welcome to "Talks at Google"
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it's my great pleasure
to introduce Tom Clynes.
Tom is a science
journalist, photographer,
and professional speaker.
He's covered environmental
issues, energy,
and science stories
around the world,
taking memorable
photos along the way.
He's here today to talk
about his latest book.
In 2010, as contributing editor
for "Popular Science Magazine,"
he wrote about a community of
nuclear physics enthusiasts,
hobbyists who were
reproducing in labs
they'd built themselves, what
scientists were accomplishing
in layou-- in the world's
most sophisticated research
facilities.
One of these amateurs was a
14-year-old boy from Texarkana
who had just become
one of 32 people
to build a working
nuclear fusion reactor.
The story Tom wrote
turned in the book
he's here to discuss today,
"The Boy Who Played with Fusion:
Extreme Science,
Extreme Parenting,
and How to Make a Star."
It's the extraordinary
account of how
one exceptionally gifted
young man, Taylor Wilson,
with nearly endless
patience and support
from his parents
and allies realized
his early potential, emphasis
on the patience and support.
Taylor's limitless curiosity
and outsized personality
have made him a force
of nature on par
with those he's
worked to harness.
This is also, I'm guessing,
the only book any of us
will read this
year that describes
a pivotal event in these terms.
The moment were a small boy
stirred his dying grandmother's
pee.
There's something unexpected
on just about every page here.
In the Q and A, you might ask
Tom about quack radium cures
in the 1920s if you want to
get into unexpected things.
In the meantime, please join
me in welcoming Tom Clynes.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM CLYNES: OK.
Thank you John, appreciate it.
And thanks everyone
for coming out.
So I want to tell you a
story about the youngest
person on Earth to achieve
a nuclear fusion reaction.
But beyond that I think
what's more interesting
is what he chose to do with
his machine that he built,
and we'll get into
some of that today.
The story is basically a
science adventure story.
It also ventures into the
outer realms of giftedness,
and genius, and creativity, and
more than anything parenting.
In fact, I started off thinking
that this was a book about kid,
but I really thought after
getting into it that it
was a book about parenting.
And Taylor himself--
I would say the things
that he's accomplished
and the things
that he continues
to accomplish are
as much as a result of
having extraordinary parents
and being gifted
with those parents
as they are with his
intellectual gifts.
And so we'll talk a
little bit about what
it means to parent a genius or
a child with any sort of gifts.
Because when we talk
about academic giftedness,
we're really talking
about 10% or up to 10%
of the population in the US.
But there's other
kinds of giftedness.
There's artistic giftedness.
There's musical giftedness
and athletic giftedness,
all kinds of things.
In fact, just about everybody
the latest science suggests
has the capacity to
work at an expert
level or a sort of
world changing level
in some domain of expertise.
The real trick is
finding and matching
those gifts with
the right domain.
And when you do find that
match, especially if you find it
early in your life
or a child's life,
it's amazing how quickly
things can happen.
So the story as John said
started with a 2010 "Popular
Science" story.
And I was really interested in
the high energy amateur science
communities.
These people that
were doing things
like splitting atoms
in their garages,
and fusing atomic nuclei
in their basement,
and building particle
accelerators,
and really doing things
that mostly people
do at these large state-funded
research laboratories.
But they were doing
them as individuals.
So I started getting
into this community.
I was really interested
that these people
had mastered both the formidable
physics of nuclear fusion--
and other sorts of
high energy physics--
and also the hands on sort
of engineering skills.
And really something
that Taylor did
requires some
expertise in about 40
different scientific
and technical fields,
everything from nuclear
engineering and plasma physics
to vacuum technology,
which is something
that I don't think you
can even go to school for.
It's sort of a black art.
You have to really figure it out
by having mentors, and doing it
yourself, and trial and error.
So the story for
me was a departure
from what I usually do.
Because it was so
incredibly optimistic.
I typically cover things
like Ebola epidemics,
and scientific slap fights
that end careers, the battle
over climate change
and the people trying
to influence that debate,
or some eco-mercenaries
in central Africa trying to
protect rhinos and elephants,
and some of their
hard drinking friends
that came along for the ride.
Actually we rescued this
guy from a bushmeat market
while we were on
that assignment.
And he quickly learned
to swipe our beers.
We didn't actually give
him beers and we wouldn't.
But you couldn't set up a beer
down for more than a couple
seconds without this chimp
running over, and grabbing
your beer, and
running up in a tree,
and laughing at you while
he downed the bottle.
So, for me getting into
something like this
was really, really different.
Taylor is a really-- he's not
your typical science nerd.
He's not over in the corner
sort of skulking at the science
fair.
He's very switched on.
He's very eyes
up, very hands on.
He's very good at drawing
people into his orbit
and talking people into things,
talking people out of things.
And he's been like this
ever since he was a child.
When he was very
small, his parents
said, Yeah, this was a really
hard kid to keep on the ground.
When he was five, he got into
construction like a lot of boys
do.
In fact my sons Charlie
and Joe are here,
and they were into
construction too.
But Taylor took it a
little bit farther.
He didn't want anything to do
with toys, construction toys,
Tonka trucks and
things like that.
For his fifth
birthday, his parents
took him to a Toys R Us store
and said pick out any crane,
because he'd said
he wanted a crane.
And he stopped his feet.
And he said, No,
I want a real one.
And so this is
about the time when
most dads would put their
own feet down and say,
what do I got to do?
Well, his dad actually
called a friend
to bring over a crane for
his fifth birthday party.
And the kids all sat on
the lap of the operator
while they swung the
boom-- this isn't it
actually-- swung the
boom over the rooftops
in the neighborhood.
And so that gives you
an idea about this sort
of intellectual spoiling that
was going on in this household,
and the very
interesting and extreme
I would say intellectual
indulgence that was happening.
Taylor got into space next.
A lot of kids do that too.
Myself, that's what I was
into when I was a kid.
But his parents would do things
like, they'd take him out
of school to visit places
like Huntsville's US Space
and Rocket Center,
or Cape Canaveral
for a launch of the shuttle.
They said, we never
had any qualms
about him missing a test
or his little brother
missing a test to do
something they wanted to do.
Because we thought it might
inform something later.
And I kind of look at that as
sort of helicopter parenting
2.0.
In that, instead of the parents
piloting the helicopters
and taking the kids
where they want to go
and hovering over them.
You're actually letting the
kids pilot the helicopters.
The parents jump on board
with the supplies, the fuel,
the mentors, the experiences.
And from what I can tell
researching the book,
I talked to dozens and dozens of
child psychologists, creativity
experts, and others,
this is really
the way you want to
cultivate a kid's talents.
And especially in
the early years
when early novel experiences are
super important for developing
these parts of the brain, they
can actually see it in scans
that the brain development
is different when kids
have early novel experiences.
And now that doesn't
mean stressful,
super stressful novel
experiences all the time,
that could be very destructive.
They've seen that in scans too.
And it's a big part
of research right now.
But Taylor was indulged,
got into chemistry,
he got into building
his own rockets.
He wanted to make his
rockets go higher and higher.
And he was buying
bigger and bigger
rockets, bigger
and bigger engines,
started building
his own rockets.
Then he was running out of money
to buy the engines to propel
the rockets.
He wanted to get them up as high
as they do in the Black Rock
Desert, when you have to get
FAA approval to shoot them off.
So he started making
his own rocket fuel.
While that meant that he
had to master chemistry.
And then he started making
his own biodiesel, which
he tried to talk
his dad into putting
into his fleet of
Coca-Cola trucks.
Now keep in mind
both his parents
had no scientific
training whatsoever.
Dad was a Coca-Cola bottler,
mom, a yoga instructor.
They both would
say we didn't know
a dang thing about science.
They're in southern
Arkansas, in Texarkana.
This is not by any means
a technical hot bed
in the US, not much
infrastructure at all.
But Taylor was mixing up
rocket fuel biodiesel.
Then he got into,
instead of seeing
how high his
rockets would go, he
got into seeing how
spectacularly he
could blow them up when
they got up in the air.
So I guess, only a
matter of time just
like the Chinese with fireworks.
And soon he was putting on
really spectacular fireworks
demonstrations all
over the neighborhood.
And 4th of July was always a
big thing around their house.
His parents didn't do-- and
this becomes even more apparent
later on-- they didn't do what
most of us sort of intuitively
do, which is keep our kids away
from things that can kill them.
They actually found
ways to help him
learn how to do things safely.
How to-- they found ways to
bring people into his life,
and bring experiences
into his life,
and bring knowledge
into his life
so that he could do
these things that
pales in comparison to blowing
a few things up in the driveway.
He was 10 years old.
And it was his birthday.
And his grandmother said, hey,
let's go to the bookstore.
I want to get you any book
you want for your birthday.
And Taylor went right to the
science section of course.
And he picked out this book
called "The Radioactive Boy
Scout."
Has anyone read
that, or know of it?
It was a kid in
suburban Detroit who
started with the nuclear
energy scout badge,
and then took it really far
and tried to build a breeder
reactor in his backyard shed.
And it eventually led to a
super fun cleanup of the house
and part of the neighborhood,
and the terrified neighbors
watching the belongings being
carted away, and eventually
led to an arrest and
really sort of went
in the opposite
direction as Taylor.
And his parents-- the kid's name
is David Hahn-- and his parents
really were the opposite
of Taylor's parents.
They didn't give him
any support at all.
They said, hey, we just
don't want you doing this.
You do this again, you're
going to be in trouble.
So he ended up going
underground with it,
with almost disastrous results.
But Taylor's parents took
him to nuclear facilities
around the country, and
gave him a Geiger counter
for his 10th birthday.
He started collecting
uranium at abandoned mines.
And this is one
that we visited when
he was a late teenager
in the Virginia mountains
north of Reno.
And went into the mine,
started digging around,
and found some nice
uranium nuggets,
and then Taylor discovered
that his pants were
radioactive on the way out and
was quite concerned about it,
and pulled them
off, and ended up
wearing my extra shorts
for the rest of the trip.
Never did figure out
where it came from.
But another thing they did as
part of their nuclear tourism
as a family was visit Los Alamos
and some of the desert sites.
This is a-- you can't even
read it-- but it says,
do not disturb until
the year 2142 AD.
It's a marker in place
at technical area 10,
outside of Los Alamos where
they did the [INAUDIBLE]
tests for the Fat Man bomb.
The summer soon became filled
with trips like this for Taylor
and his little brother Joey.
Taylor, out in the
desert to scan around
for radioactive
materials, and as Tiffany,
his mom said, Yeah this is
how we spend our vacations.
But then things got
really a bit more scary.
Taylor started
collecting things,
and it's amazing what you
can get on eBay still as
long as you don't
call it radioactive.
Because essentially the
people that are monitoring
this kind of thing
are completely inept.
If you don't call it nuclear
or radioactive or other
certain key phrases, you
can sell just about anything
by describing it
kind of what it is
but not using certain keywords.
Taylor started bringing
home things that
literally glowed in the dark.
He started taking apart
the old computer monitors
from his school,
building an x-ray machine
by reversing things
around, learning
to use shielding for that.
He started collecting
things like spent fuel
rods from the Kerr-McGee plant
where Karen Silkwood worked.
And at some point-- well
all along-- his parents
were very concerned
about safety.
So they're bringing
in various people,
trying to figure out what--
is what he's doing safe?
But they really didn't know.
When Tiffany and Kenneth
questioned him about safety,
Taylor spoke convincingly if
bafflingly about time doses
and distance intensities
of inverse square laws
and roentgen submultiples.
He explained the different
types of radiation alpha,
beta, gamma, x-ray, and how they
dictated the amount and kind
of shielding necessary.
With his new phone-- newfound
knowledge Taylor insisted,
he could master
the furtive energy
that seeped from his rocks and
metals and other collectibles.
I know what I'm doing,
Taylor reassured his parents.
I'm the responsible
radioactive Boy Scout.
One afternoon Tiffany
ducked her head
into Taylor's garage laboratory
to call him in for supper.
And she saw her son in his
yellow hazmat overalls,
watching a pool of
liquid as it spread
from an overturned container
across the concrete floor.
Tay, it's time for supper.
I'm going to have to
clean this up first.
That's not the stuff you said
would kill us if it broke open,
Tiffany asked.
Is it?
I don't think so, Taylor said.
Not instantly.
[LAUGHTER]
So, he started collecting
a lot of uranium rocks, ore
and about this time, he was 11.
He found out that his
grandmother was dying.
Now she'd had cancer
for a long time.
It had been in remission.
It came back.
And she was really
his biggest fan
and his closest-- the person
that was closest to him.
And Taylor approached this
in a very interesting way.
He asked her for a
sample of her urine
after she came
back from her test,
because it was very radioactive.
And then he also asked her
for a sample of the tumors
that she was coughing
up from her lungs.
And he said, I know this is
weird but interestingly--
scientifically it was
very interesting to me,
and she indulged me.
Taylor was also-- his mind
was working this whole time.
He was 11 years old.
He didn't want to
lose his grandmother.
But pretty soon
everybody was saying,
there's nothing more
anyone can do for grandma.
And Taylor was
thinking, well gosh
there's got to be
something somebody can do.
So he'd been thinking about how
radioactive isotopes are made.
And usually they're made in
these multimillion dollar
cyclotrons.
There's only a few in the world.
They're shipped very
quickly by private jet
to distribution facilities
around the world.
They have to be shipped
quickly because they're
half lives are so short.
They need to get in,
light up the tumors,
and then decay away before
they can do much more damage.
So Taylor started
thinking, well I
wonder if there's a
different way of doing this.
Because he'd been working
with a nuclear pharmacist, who
had become a mentor to him.
And he'd asked the guy,
David Boudreaux, so
how do people in Africa get
these things when they're sick?
And he said, well unfortunately
Taylor, usually they can't.
They're not really available.
It's just too expensive.
So one day, he and I were making
some yellowcake in his garage.
And he told me about this
day he was stirring up
his grandmother's pee
and holding the Geiger
counter to it, measuring it.
And he got this idea.
Well, what about using
nuclear fusion to make
radioactive medical isotopes?
And it was a novel idea for an
11-year-old to think of this.
So anyway, he started
thinking, well
if I could build
a reactor that was
small enough and safe
enough and cheap enough
to put in every electrified
hospital on earth.
How many more lives
could be saved?
How much cheaper could it be?
How many more people could
we get these things to?
And so at that
point, he realized
that's what he wanted
to do with his life.
And this notion of-- I guess
a future image of oneself
is extremely important in the
development of most people
who have had big creative
breakthroughs in their lives.
People who have pushed certain
fields of knowledge forward.
And Taylor saw himself as
not only doing this thing,
but also as being a
groundbreaking nuclear
physicist when he was older.
So this would end up propelling
him for the next several years
as he pursued this idea.
After his grandmother passed
away, he started looking into,
how can I build a
nuclear fusion reactor?
At this point, only 10 people
as individuals had ever done it.
And so he started
writing to people
and sort of getting--
trying to find
somebody that could help them.
Well this is very difficult
because of where he lived.
How could an 11-year-old
kid living into Texarkana
ever hope to achieve
this kind of thing?
But he was an extremely
resourceful kid.
He was able to find a mentor,
by the name of Carl Willis.
And eventually would meet
him and Kenneth and Tiffany
would bring him to meet
him in Albuquerque.
Now Carl is a nuclear
engineer with a PhD,
and he took Taylor
under his wing.
And he was the 10th person to
build a working nuclear fusion
reactor.
He said, well
Taylor this is going
to be extremely difficult to do.
But he never said,
you'll never do it.
In fact, he sent Taylor a
neutron detector thinking
that some day he might.
So I went with these guys to
a place called the Black Hole,
which is outside of Los Alamos.
And it's defunct now,
but it is a place
where the weapons industry,
nuclear weapons industry,
sends its surplus gear.
So we went shopping there
one day for equipment.
This is sort of Taylor's version
of a light bulb going off
over his head.
But he scanned the aisles
and came out with some stuff
and filled the shopping cart,
and had some complex fittings,
and some detectors and
a lot of spare parts,
and brought it up
to the check-out.
And he said, all right, mom
I want to buy this stuff.
She says, what do you
want all this stuff for?
He says, I want to build a
second reactor for the house.
And she said,
Taylor, you are not
going to build a nuclear
reactor in the house.
But he ended up coming
away with the stuff.
As I said, he was very good
at talking people into things.
So he would do things
like, he found out
that an astronaut in Houston
was selling a mass spectrometer,
an instrument that
Taylor could cannibalize
for parts for his particle
accelerator and his fusers.
So the guy wanted
several thousand dollars
for this thing.
And Taylor just called
him up and said,
Hey, I'm 11 years old,
and I was wondering
if you'd consider donating it
to me for the nuclear fusion
reactor I want to build.
This is the way this
kid's life works, right?
This is just the way
things roll for him.
And the guy said, well,
can you come pick it up?
So his dad got one of
the Coca-Cola trucks
to go down to Houston
and pick it up.
And Taylor started putting
this thing together.
Well again, he was now
12, 13, and lacking really
the expertise or the mentors
to be able to pull this off,
especially where he lived.
Now with any gifted
kids if any of you
have kids that
are gifted, you're
going to run up
against a problem
that Kenneth and Tiffany ran up
against, which is the schools.
The schools in this
country by and large
just can't handle these kids.
We had a golden age of
specialized gifted education
after Sputnik, when suddenly
we saw America's smartest kids
as being a national resource
and national security resource
even.
And so a lot of
energy money was put
into developing science
labs, developing
learning opportunities,
acceleration,
special opportunities for kids.
As soon as the Cold War ended,
the interest in gifted kids
really started to fade.
And then you had a sort
of anti-elitist movement
that was going on
in the '80s, where
the thought of segregating
kids because they're smart
was thought to be maybe
not such a good idea.
Because well, are the other
kids getting a second class
education?
And if those kids
that were smart
happened to be already
advantaged socially,
race, class, then it was
even more problematic.
But in any case, gifted
education programs
began to go out of fashion.
And they disappeared
most quickly
in the more PC communities
like Cambridge, and Ann Arbor,
Michigan, where my
kids go to school.
One of the things I
encountered in my research
was that they're trying
to figure out what do we
do with these programs?
We can-- we don't-- we're not
going to have any more pulling
these kids out of
these program--
of their regular classrooms.
We're going to
have to figure out
some other way of doing this.
And so the school system
in Ann Arbor in the mid-90s
did a survey of parents.
And this is in
every college town
it would probably be the same.
They asked the parents
all kinds of things
about gifted education,
other kinds of education.
One of the questions was,
are your own kids gifted?
Well, in a college
town, what do you
think was the response
to that question?
What percentage of respondents
answered, yes, my own kids
are gifted?
It turns out that 99% of
parents in Ann Arbor, Michigan
thought that.
I have no doubt that Cambridge
would be pretty much the same.
But you know it's not
actually-- it doesn't
take an evolutionary biologist,
or psychologist to understand
why we all think their kids
deserve special treatment.
And why we think our
own kids are gifted.
I've got two geniuses
here in the front row.
And the thing is that the same
developmental processes really
guide the development
of gifts, whether you--
no matter what level
you're working at.
And as I said before,
really everyone
is gifted in
certain-- in some way.
There's some sort of
specialty that everybody's
going to be great at if
you manage to match them
with the right thing.
So for Taylor what happened
was that schools just
weren't going to do the job.
He spent most of
the time waiting.
And that's the response
that researchers
got when they asked gifted
kids across the country, what's
your school experience?
Most of them said, waiting.
Describe it in
one word, waiting.
Always waiting for the
rest of class to catch up.
Waiting for the teacher
to teach something
that I don't already know.
So they ended up finding
this school in Reno, Nevada
and deciding to move there.
It's a public school for
kids that score in the 99.9th
percentile on the
standardized tests.
It's called Davidson Academy.
And it's parked on the campus
of University of Nevada, Reno.
So Taylor went there.
It turns out the physics
department's quite good there.
So he was very happy about that.
And ended up there.
And ended up finding
mentors there.
He found-- went
to some professors
and was turned down
once, and went to the guy
next door, by the name of
Ron Phaneuf, a famous plasma
physicist.
And said, hey, I want to build
a nuclear fusion reactor.
And I want to do
it in my garage.
And Taylor said, well-- or
Ron said, well, my god, we
can't have you do
it in you garage,
but maybe we could
figure out a way for you
to try it here in the sub
basement of the physics lab.
So that's exactly what they did.
So Ron and Bill Brinsmead,
the physics department's
chief technician, a super
eccentric and fascinating guy,
ended up becoming
Taylor's mentors.
And they worked with
him over many months
to eventually build-- help
him build this nuclear fusion
reactor.
And he mastered all
these technical fields,
and eventually got it
to work, got neutrons,
and was recognized for it.
He became the 32nd
person on Earth
to achieve nuclear
fusion as an individual.
Here he is running the
control panel of the machine.
And here is the grid with
the plasma field around it.
What was most interesting though
about this machine was not
really its-- the machine
itself but what he did with it.
So we went together
once to a field outside
of the airport of Albuquerque
International Airport, which
is shared with the
Sandia Air Force Base.
And it turns out that a really
weird thing happened there
in the '50s, 1957, when a
nuclear bomb was accidentally
dropped in a field on approach.
And it was probably the sort of
closest to Doctor Strangelove
moment that the Air
Force has ever had,
where one of the
crewmen was sent back
to check on the
bomb to make sure
it was secure, and ended
up pulling the wrong lever.
The bomb dropped
from its platform
on to the bomb bay
doors, forced them open,
and then fell 3,000 feet
and exploded in a field.
Now luckily the plutonium
core wasn't in it
or all of Albuquerque
would be gone, gone, gone.
But there was a lot of
radioactive material in it.
This so called spark plug that
surrounds the plutonium core.
And Taylor got his hands on
some declassified documents,
and found out where
this had happened,
or roughly where it happened,
and went out and found it.
And they said they
had cleaned it up.
But we ended up finding all
kinds of radioactive debris.
There's Taylor and
Carl looking at it.
So the first time
he went there, he
was shipping it home in a
box through the airports
and TSA looked at it.
They had a piece of
white tape across it when
he took it off the bag check.
And there's a little note inside
that said, we checked this.
And Taylor said, wow,
they had no idea what
they were looking at.
They weren't checking
for radiation.
So he started thinking
about the tens of thousands
of shipping containers that
enter the US every month,
every week actually.
About 10,000 a day I think.
And they're sort of
the soft underbelly
as far as nuclear security
in that hardly any of them
are checked, and when they are,
it just slows down everything.
It's very hard.
So he got this idea
to develop a detector
that trucks could
drive through and it
could shoot a directed
neutron beam at the contents.
And if there were any
fissionable materials
inside the box, it would pick
them up and alert the operator.
It would also pick
up nitrogen signals,
signatures from any
conventional explosives.
So we took this to
the science fair.
And the first year
he was there, he just
entered the reactor and some
neutron multiplication stuff.
And it was sort
of like, wow a kid
shows up at the science
fair with a nuclear reactor.
And it's like a Ferrari showing
up at a Soapbox Derby, right?
So wins big in physics, the
second year he wins bigger.
The third year, he ends up
with a security application,
and he wind it all.
He wins the intell--
young scientist award
and becomes this superstar.
And $50,000 award with
several other awards
stacked on top of it, a
trip to CERN in Switzerland.
And then I do my story
in "Popular Science."
So his life starts to
get really interesting.
So Chris Anderson, who curates
TED, got a hold of the story
in "Pop Sci" and
said, my god, we
got to get this
kid to talk at TED.
Taylor's only prepared
for one talk in his life
and it was a disaster.
This one he didn't
prepared at all for.
His only preparation was
calling me an hour and a half
before he was due to go on
stage and saying, hey Tom,
can you email me some slides?
That was it.
So he comes back next year.
He's getting more
and more famous.
He's invited to the
National Ignition Facility
to give a talk.
He's a big shot at his school.
At this school, there's
no football team.
It doesn't get bigger
than what he was doing.
He's invited to the Halifax
Security Conference.
And he's sitting between the
Palestinians and Israelis
and talking about how we
might be able to get along.
And then he says to his
math teacher one day.
Hey, can I have the
homework ahead of time?
I've got to go to Washington.
What's going on in Washington?
Well, I've got to go
meet the President.
Sure enough, he's
invited to talk to Obama.
Some other kids were there too.
Obama was talking to every
kid, so, nice to see you.
These two start
riffing and talking,
what do your parents
think of all this?
This is crazy.
And then, Obama
says, so when are
you going to come work for me?
And Taylor says, well
I kind of thought
that was why I was here.
So Obama makes the rounds.
He comes back to
Taylor on the way out.
And he says, yeah,
you're definitely going
to be working for me soon.
Several people that
heard about this
thought that it might end
up being the other way
around, actually.
Obama might end up
working for Taylor.
So he's getting a
very, very big profile.
So what happens to a teenager
when someone is calling him
genius and Einstein every day?
Well, what happened was
sort of the dark side
of this kind of
thing, and really
the dark side of giftedness.
And he abandoned some
of his old friends
to have lunch with a new
girl that he liked a lot.
He was driving
everybody crazy at home.
He was demanding to
watch his own TV shows,
shows that featured him.
Got addicted to the spotlight.
And so sometimes by indulging
this sort of showman thing,
these super smart kids
learn that if they keep up
the demands, they'll be met,
which really doesn't do them
a lot of good in the long run.
And this sense of
entitlement and a really sort
of a narcissistic tendency
will the overconfidence it
will get challenged eventually.
Sometimes a gifted
kid, their identity
will get caught up
in being a whiz kid.
So sometimes they
will stop trying
to be anything else than
what protects that identity.
There's some really,
really, really interesting
educational theories about that.
If you really want a kid to
be smart and keep being smart,
whatever you don't
tell them their smart.
Tell them that
they're hard workers.
It's a really common scenario.
Also he was putting a lot
of energy into the science,
and into sort of even
self-promotion I would say.
And it wasn't going into
really self-awareness and some
of the social,
emotional sort of tasks.
So I'm going to read a
couple more paragraphs
by way of wrapping it up.
I will say that the people
who are worried about Taylor,
at this point in his life,
when he was 16, 17, 18
are still his friends.
And Taylor and I
are still close.
He-- when he saw the book,
and he saw for the first time
what some of the people
that were closest to him
were saying about him
during this period,
it was really actually
very hard for him.
Since then he was able
to rebuild things.
And he did it by returning
to really his roots.
What he had envisioned
when he was 11,
himself sort of saving his
grandmother's life by building
these medical isotopes.
And so he got to work in that.
He sort of buried himself
in science for a year.
And when he came back
up, he'd finished
this device that would allow
them to create these isotopes.
But in the meantime,
this sort of really this
nadir in his life.
I'm going to read you
some of the things
that people were saying.
His friend, Bill Brinsmead,
his number one mentor, he said,
my worry, says
Brinsmead, is that it
could have an unhappy ending.
What happens when everything
he does doesn't succeed?
Some kids burn out.
They're so intense, so young.
And they get to
be 20 and they're
hanging out on Telegraph
Avenue in Berkeley.
Then again Taylor's successes
were a relatively recent thing.
He'd had plenty
of early failures,
maybe they would gird
him against the downfall
that so many people
worried about.
Maybe so, Brinsmead said.
But right now he's
headstrong, and he's
playing games with people.
It may be just a phase,
and he'll get through it.
But right now I just feel
sorry for his parents
and for Joey, that's
his little brother.
I'd already confided
to his parents,
Tiffany and Kenneth,
who looked exhausted,
that I was beginning
to worry that I'd
helped to create a monster with
my magazine story about Taylor.
I think we'll get through
this, Tiffany said.
But honestly Tom we
just want it to be over.
We're ready for him to move on
so we can concentrate on Joey.
Taylor as a high school
student had already
done things that would
be the envy of most PhDs.
Everywhere you turned,
someone was calling him
a genius or an Einstein.
But Taylor wasn't ready
to be an Einstein.
And as those closest
to him watched
hi celebrity status
grow, they saw
the traits that had
brought him this far,
his passion and curiosity,
his exuberance, his confidence
devolving into hubris.
Taylor's arrogance
and narcissism
were having corrosive
effects on himself
and everyone around him.
The lesson of the Icarus
myth came to mind.
How could it not?
But Icarus' story
wasn't a perfect fit.
After all Icarus hadn't
put the sun in a box.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
So, that's the only
picture of Joey
that we have, with his back to
the camera, very different kid
than Taylor.
And this brings up one
of the other issues when
you have more than one
kid and the first one's
a superstar sucking all
the air out of the room.
Sometimes the other ones
left with the leftovers.
Joey wasn't interested
in being a superstar.
He was interested in doing math.
He was an extremely bright
kid, as bright as Taylor.
But he would-- his
mother would go
into the shower or the bathroom
after he was in the shower,
and see that he'd drawn
calculus equations on the steam
in the shower door.
He had no interest in being
a showman like Taylor.
But he was just as smart.
So what do you do
with the introverted
sort of gifted kids?
Do you want to
hear about the time
we went to the set of
the "Big Bang Theory,"
Taylor and I. That's fun.
So we went to see the live
taping of the "Big Bang
Theory."
These are sort of
excruciating experiences,
if you've ever been to a live
TV show taping of a comedy.
You've got this overbearing
emcee, trying to get the crowd
to laugh on the fourth take,
just as hard as you laughed
the first time you saw
the skit, heard the joke.
And it's just hard
to sit through.
But anyway afterwards,
we were invited down
to the cast and crew's
Christmas party.
And Taylor's sitting
in Sheldon's spot
with Johnny Galecki.
And he looks over to the
shelf, and you can see this
on the show, where
this instrument is
sitting on one of the shelf.
It's a Korean war
era Geiger counter.
And Taylor recognized it.
He said, hey that
prop over there.
Those things they had a
radioactive source in them.
And they were supposed
to take them out
when they decommissioned them,
but they miss a lot of them.
You want me to go take a look.
And so at this point, Chuck
Lorre is brought over.
And he says, Yeah definitely.
So they bring a screwdriver, and
Taylor takes this thing apart.
And bingo, he finds this
disc of strontium 90
that's been quietly
irradiating the cast and crew
for the last five years.
And Taylor says, wow that
would make a nice souvenir.
You want me to take
it out of there?
And Chuck Lorre says, and
get it the heck off the set.
Yes.
So Taylor ended up
with a nice souvenir.
This is David Saltzberg,
he's the science adviser
for the show.
And he said, Yeah I
think this will go down
in "Big Bang Theory"
lore, Taylor, as one
of the interesting moments.
Anyway let's-- let's
take some questions.
AUDIENCE: So
everything I've read
and I think a lot of people know
this, a lot of these extremely
capable young people
turn out to be
just kind of regular
old really smart adults.
And likewise, extremely
capable adults
were not child prodigies.
Given that why do you
think people are just
so obsessed and interested
in kids like Tom-- sorry,
kids like Taylor?
TOM CLYNES: I wish they
were obsessed and interested
in kids like Tom.
Well, I mean we love to hear it.
It's a great story, right?
I mean it's amazing
but you're right.
Sometimes the
mistake people make
is closing the door too soon.
A lot of kids are
early bloomers.
A lot are bloomed right in
the middle, most of them.
Some are late bloomers.
The trick for parents
is to be watching
for those sparks of interest and
talent and to pick up on them
and feed them, and to not
close the door too soon
on a kid who's seemingly
interested in nothing
or a late bloomer.
Lots of times early bloomers
do burn out as well.
And we talked about
some of the reasons why.
It's just that they
get so caught up
in being that smart
kid, that they instead
of taking risks and bringing
themselves to the next level
constantly, and
learning to do things
for the sake of learning
and doing, and being
willing to fail.
Instead of doing
that, they end up
sort of buttressing this image
of themselves as the smart kid.
So you don't take risks because
you might fail at something.
And then you're not the
super smart kid anymore.
You're not the whiz kid.
So that's a super big problem.
There's a theory
called Mindset theory
that Carol Dweck
has come up with.
And it's quite interesting, just
about how you encourage kids.
Just as far as OK,
it's not because you're
smart that you achieve things.
It's because you try hard
that you achieve things.
And because you're willing to
fail that you achieve things.
So we often-- we make
mistakes with gifted kids,
with every kid.
This doesn't apply
just to gifted kids.
We have to really I think be
on the lookout for these, again
these sparks of talent and
interest and then feed them.
And even when you're
an adult, OK, it's
not your parent's
responsibility anymore,
but it's our own responsibility
to find the things that
make the most sense to
us and that we're good at
and that we can really excel at.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
wondering what you
think of the role of
competition in academics?
So the US, you may know, for won
the International Math Olympiad
beating China and
other countries
for the first time
in over 20 years.
It seems like those
kind of competitions
can really be both
a cure for hubris,
too early, because
there's always
other people trying hard,
as well as a motivator
for these kinds of students.
TOM CLYNES: Yeah it's
great, great stuff.
Competition, science
fairs, math Olympiads
are just fantastic events.
And the great
thing about them is
that it takes some of the
focus away from the kids
who are the athletic
superstars and the entertainers
and so forth, and
puts it on kids
that are going to find a cure
for a certain kind of cancer
or treatment or whatever.
And these are the
kids that we should
be making into superstars
and really pumping up.
Now, was that a fluke
that we won that Olympiad?
I don't know.
I mean our scores in
general keep going down
and down and down compared
to other countries.
And our scores-- our top
student's scores have really
gone down in the past 30 years.
Vietnam, which has a per
capita GDP of somewhere 2
or $3000 a year,
a small fraction
of the US's kicks our butts
every year in math and science.
So I think we have got our
priorities in the wrong place.
That's probably a fairly obvious
thing to say, and it's no news.
But if we're able
to shift and make
these kids into some
sort of superstars
on the level of
athletes than great.
And that's what really a
lot of the physics community
thinks of Taylor.
They see him as a really
good communicator.
I think that might
be his biggest
impact beyond the science,
beyond his inventions.
I think that he has already
and could bring more people--
get more people
interested in science--
all kinds of science,
not just physics.
AUDIENCE: I'm interested
to learn a bit more
about his parents.
And on the topic of Carol
Dweck and growth mindset,
it seems pretty clear his
parents had a growth mindset.
I'm curious, was
that something they
were overtly conscious about?
Did it just come naturally?
TOM CLYNES: They didn't know it.
This is something that just
came naturally to them.
They didn't start out with
any sort of intentionality
to their parenting, whatsoever.
They had a kid that
came out on the run
basically, out of
the womb on the run.
And a lot their
parenting style evolved
because of the kind
of kid Taylor was.
That's what you see with
a lot of these kids.
The parents aren't
pushing the kids,
the kids are pulling the
parents along into things.
Now this whole business of
this intellectual spoiling,
creating this climate of
emotional and intellectual
support in the house that
was really quite extreme,
especially when he got into
these super harrowing sorts
of things that were literally
glowing in the dark.
This was something that
they saw his passion for it,
and they were inspired.
They didn't feel like they
could take it away from him.
And so they had to pro-- but
they had to protect themselves,
they had to protect the family.
They had to make sure he didn't
kill anyone, or blow things
up, or get them all set
up with early cancers.
So they were able to bring in
mentors, and other learning
opportunities, and really
take him places far away.
And I think that
was something that
was just sort of instinctive.
I talked to one person,
a child psychologist
David Feldman, that
studied these sort
of super precocious kids.
And he had an interesting theory
that could never be proven.
And he's just kind of throwing
it out on a whim really.
But it's because he can't
explain it any other way.
Well maybe just as there might
have been a scientist somewhere
back in the gene pool
that resulted in Taylor,
there might have been
a parenting style
back who knows how
many generations that
was like Taylor and
Tiffany's, and that
was appropriate for
the time and the place.
And it might not have
worked in 16th century
Bologna or something,
or with a kid who was
interested in something else.
But a lot of things
lined up for Taylor,
just a lot of what makes
these gifted kids succeed
is actually luck.
They need support.
There's no question about it.
They can't do it themselves.
They need the innate talent.
They need mentorship and
resources and so forth.
But they also just need luck.
They need the right
time and place.
They need to come
onto this earth,
and find a place like
Davidson Academy,
and find people like Ron and
Bill that could help them.
And that's not so easy.
We can't-- we can make our
own luck to a certain extent
as a democracy.
And we probably should make a
little bit more of our own luck
in that regard.
But most of the kids that have
that sort of innate capability
are not going to get
that kind of support.
And they're not going
to be able to develop
to their full potential
as a result. OK.
It looks like we're out of time.
And thanks a lot everybody,
appreciate you coming out,
and I'll be glad to talk
with anybody or sign books
or whatnot afterwards.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]